our next speaker
was once referred to by a head of state
we're talking like a national leader
as the good doctor and it's true i've
seen it
and i do believe president obama also
said i can't pronounce your name and
that's why you refer to you like that
from then on
so with that everyone please welcome to
the stage
the good doctor abbajet so
i'm going to talk today about uh
health data that is available
relatively freely and relatively
copiously around the world
um through open data initiatives
uh with various governments so first of
all
many of you may not know who i am yes i
you know that that little
tidbit i had a opportunity to
be on tv with president obama about five
years ago
um but that's the limits of my claim to
fame so i'm just going to introduce
myself a little bit
i'm a local here in dc i know this is no
longer our data
you know it's no longer our conference
dc but nonetheless
um i co-founded uh stats programming dc
with mark weissman who you guys heard
yesterday
i've been using rs for god knows how
long
um over 20 years um i think my first
version was like
0.3 or something like that and i'm an
occasional blogger
um work-wise there's i've got my hands
in a few pies i'm
do data science at a startup locally um
across the river from dc in arlington
virginia
but i also for most of my time
right now do biostatistics and machine
learning um currently at astrazeneca
and no i do not know anything about the
vaccine um
and i was at nih for a decade doing sort
of the same stuff
um i also teach um r
um again with mark we tend to do a few
things together over the last 10 years
at georgetown and i'm also adjuncted
george mason which are two
universities that are relatively known
and i teach r and python both in the
university setting as well as
for corporate trainings and the like so
stay busy in terms of both
learning r teaching r using r
um i'm not quite as fanatic as jared i
think but i'm
probably pretty close because i actually
still also use python so
jared still um so why am i talking about
open data in healthcare well i've been
interested for a long time in global
health
and uh the sustainment the sustainable
development goals
um that the who put out you know several
years ago
and sort of trying to understand why
some countries do better than others
this sort of been a personal interest
and that's when i got
um used to using world bank and who data
and discovering sort of the packages
that were there in r for accessing those
kinds of data
um going into pharma there's more of a
um an interest in what's called real
world evidence
which is basically everything that's not
a clinical trial um
so it's the publicly and some
non-publicly available data
um that's from observational studies or
from other kinds of studies that you
want to leverage to try and figure out
uh who you want to address and what are
the problems that you need to solve
and then in work i was dealing with um
questions about hospital utilization
among medicare
recipients and got to work with the
american community survey data
once again through our packages
for those who don't know the american
community survey there it is
a survey that's annual but it's run by
the census
um it's run by census bureau
and it is published every year in either
one
three or five year aggregates and it
covers sort of a subset of the questions
that are asked on the census
so thinking about open data
there's plenty of things out there and
there's plenty of ways of getting at it
right so if it's
on the web we can always you know web
scrape
and there's great tools like httr and
rvest within the r
ecosystem that allow you to do that
i'm not going to talk about web scraping
today um there's people who do it much
better than i do
there's also just straight up
availability of data sets on websites so
think
of places like data.gov where you can
just download data sets
um after some searching and so on and so
forth
and that's great and most of the time
you can get data sets in csv format or
excel
um i've actually seen
data sets from um mit that are actually
in our data format
which i got a little kick out of that
they'd actually do that officially
and then um
the other form and then hang on
i lost my i lost my place my my desktop
so just hang on there we go and then
there's apis
and apis are fantastic and they're
actually more and more available
if you want to learn more about directly
about apis and how
they work in r um go back to last year's
dcr
and mark's talk on apis
that he gave last year which was a great
introduction to how to use apis through
r
and there's video and slides and all of
that available out in the
in the internet and then finally of
course there's
our packages and of course we're in our
conference you know
ideally we want to talk about our
packages at the end of the of the day
so there's plenty of things out there to
access data
so all that motivation and then 2020
happens
and what that means is this
right we're sort of in the middle and of
all of this
and i started way back in march to start
accessing
the johns hopkins data and start doing
some of these basic visualizations that
it
that sort of uh the financial times does
as well in the new york and the new york
times
but just to play around with how to grab
data how to do these kinds of
visualizations playing around with
with ggplot um i haven't done these for
several months because there's
professionals who are doing these kinds
of things and
um they're much better than i am but it
also got me
really realizing the power of open data
to aggregate all of these
different despair data sets into one
place so that we can do these kinds of
visualizations
both the hopkins people as well as the
new york times
um the kova tracking project which is an
astonishing project because they
at least when i last went deeply into
them were doing things literally by hand
um of aggregating these open data
sources and putting them into one
essential repository and sort of
aligning things so that
we can use it and for the covid world
you know the three of these four data
sources have github
repos available for the data and so we
have the tools in our to just download
these repos
and access the data and for the kobe
tracking project there's actually an api
available which will give you either
json or csv files
it's just standard rest api that you
could potentially access via
hdtr for example so open data is great
and
really the covet the last seven months
eight months whatever it is now
really showed us how much open data can
be leveraged which
is fantastic there's obviously a caveat
with open data and open government data
in that there's a great deal of
variability in the completeness and the
quality of the data
um and there's other various problems in
terms of ascertainment
and how you call someone a patient how
you call something
death a covet-related death and so on
and so forth which is
absolutely not even around the world and
um so data quality is still an issue but
the fact that you have access to at
least
you know reasonable reasonable amounts
of data that are contemporaneous is
is fantastic
so for open data um this is actually
from data.gov they have a map
on and open data's gotten
these are government sources and it's
pretty widespread
at least in the oecd countries in india
china russia
those are the country-wide ones and then
the the markers there
are actually city or state open data
portals
so it's not just the national level data
that's available but also
state and local data which also is
fantastic because it gives you some
granularity
so in the federal government um is
required to
publish their data online with open
standards
under the open government data act of
2018.
um the biggest sort of catalog of this
is data.gov
it has over 218 000 data sets
um there's also a healthdata.gov which
is more interesting to me
and it provides data from different
agencies under the
the department of health and human
services as well as partner cities and
states
and it's really focused on health care
and and and allied
subjects so
apis in government data have
become much more prevalent which is a
good thing
and there appears to be three general
api
infrastructures if you will that are in
common use for open data
if they're not actually having custom
rest apis available so the three are the
socrata
open data api or soda ccan and dkan
and true to government there's no one
api to rule them all the cdc uses soda
data.gov uses can
as does the uk government the european
union used to use ckin but now use a
custom
rest api healthdata.gov which is
you would think aligned to data.gov uses
dcan
and then just to put a spanner in the
words the fda just
did their own thing um so
you need to know a bit of different apis
and api calls and digging in
to get at different aspects of health
data
even within the u.s federal system
more globally the world health
organization which of course
is looks at data and collects
data from various countries around the
world provides not one but two apis
uh to its global health observatory one
uses the open data api and the other
uses the athena api
and the world bank which everyone thinks
of as an economics powerhouse but
they have actually have great data on
national
health statistics has its own api
at ap api.bank.org so we've got a bunch
of apis
most of the apis will give you json data
and so the basic tools are httr to grab
the data and then json lite xml
or other packages to parse the data
but i'm lazy and i love r
so i don't want to do all this hard work
of figuring out the apis and
um and actually scraping them and and
making
putting the calls out and pulling them
back so what do i do why
i look around for our packages to do
this stuff
and so fortunately the our ecosystem is
fantastic because
there are interested developers who have
our packages that just
wrapped various apis so for the world
bank
um there's actually two packages wdi is
a little older wb stats is a little
newer
slightly different syntaxes
but fairly straightforward um
you can basically put the indicators
that you want the the world bank
indicators are
very cryptic um and so it's worth like
looking at the world bank's site
to figure out what these indicators
codes are but once you have them
downloading the data is a one line
command and then you can
do what you will because this comes down
to a data frame
the who also has an api
um the r package also called who
um it's not on cran it's on github and
it gives me a little more control
because it also it
allows me to download the actual codes
the indicator codes
and so once i have that i can actually
use r to do my searches and filters
to figure out the codes i actually need
to ask for um
to actually get the data that i'm
interested in so in this case i'm
showing you an example
of getting life expectancy at birth for
different countries over different years
the fda like i said has its own api
and it does a bunch of data
makes a bunch of data available um on
drugs devices and food
what's actually often really interesting
is that there have a lot of
information about drug recalls or food
recalls
and adverse events and um these are
things that are often really really
interesting to look at simply because it
goes to the safety
and whether i should you know you know
use a food or a drug
um so there's a lot of there's a lot of
data out there you know it's a really
big database
um there is an open fda package that
uses that fda
api um it is
it's very thin wrapper around it so it's
almost like
piece by piece going through and just
recreating the api call
i'm just showing you an easy example
here where i'm looking at
all the drugs in the fda database and at
what age
uh patients got them and so this is
almost patient level data and you can
see that we have
you know on the y-axis we're going up to
150 000
uh counts so most drugs obviously in the
us are
you know in the 40 to 80 age range
and of course there's much fewer that
are in the pediatric ranges
um so it mentions to crowd us he can and
d can
so all three have wrappers in r which is
cool
um the r socrata package is the one i'm
highlighting
simply because socrata seems to be the
most widely
used across a lot of government
databases
i'm just giving an example here for the
cdc i'm grabbing
um the number of covet deaths in
maryland by week
i actually went to the cdc website and
figured and found out what the api call
was
and so i can just get that api call put
it into read to krata
and i get a data frame that then i can
i'm just using tidyburst to
sort of filter it out for maryland and
then um showing a plot
showing that we had our last really bad
peak
in what is it may june to early summer
but we're going up the uphill again and
as we go to the end of the year
and since it's 2020 there's plenty of
covert data packages these were the
early ones that i played with which were
covet 19 coronavirus
tidy covet i'm sure there's more data
packs that have mushroomed since
then google will be your friend
and so i guess the overall point is that
there is data that you can use
from government sources that are
available that are easy to
access from r and allow you a great deal
of power to
do your own analyses and do your own
sort of understanding of the underlying
data to for either your own
benefit or your works benefit um
and we can do it all in our which is
which i think is is the best part of
this
story um not all the apis out there have
rappers so obviously there's
work to be done by the community to help
us out lazy people like me
to make more packages that so i can get
them
so thank you very much for your time and
the slides are actually available on
github um there's a url on github pages
for all these slides if you want to
access them again so thank you very much
for your
time and your attention thank you very
much
and actually brings up a great point we
get this question this question is asked
all the time
all of the talks will be posted online
at rstats.ai
within about a month um it takes a
little bit time as i mentioned yesterday
we actually have a former nickelodeon
double dare
nfl films producer uh handling of our
video
takes a little bit of time but as soon
as they're ready i'm usually about a
month because it's a lot of
very high-res images videos
and we'll post it up at rstats.ai and at
rstats.ai
you can find videos of all the talks in
the past six years
of conferences both the new york
conference and this government
conference
so hop on over there to uh see videos
so just a few um